[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for Jack Reacher episode six Jack Jack
sixer Jack shoot six shooter six
shooting Jack oh yeah boom we got some
we got one in there leave a like on this
video ladies and gentlemen that'd be
very much appreciated also subscribe
click the notification Bell get notified
when I reaction for Jack heads up 7even
up is up on the channel and thank you to
prepper Jack prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights who's your
favorite member of the 110th though
leave it down below we should ask a
question when the reaction is happening
that way they know to answer then cuz
they probably skipped over to this part
that's how we create engagement H I
learn some new every full length re
action watch along we seek with your own
copy of Jack Reacher available for super
sex rejects over at our patreon page we
also cover several things over there
exclusive with highlights and watch
Longs included I'm ready to watch this
are you I am so ready but before that
tell us in the comments what is your
favorite's your favorite the
one what do you think they used
hmx hmx could be2 but hmx is a more
readily available explosive who cares
what they used I'm more interested in
who used it Swan Swan did it give it up
I'm really the only one here that's
going to say it
Swan hired by Swan he was going to get
paid by swan he got his ass blown
halfway across the street by Swan Swan
had a good reason all right I'm not
going to assume Swan's dirty in an
investigation assumptions kill so the
military grade Munitions bomb squad Farm
remnants of a trip wired Rigg IED what
are you doing at my favorite
pot kids play here well what we do know
is they plan was to have you all killed
in the bone yard and then take out the
Assassins here no Loose Ends bodies just
the snipers the pal Swan wasn't there
uhoh so he's innocent a
[__]
yeah you call me on my
phone where okay send me the address
someone in the comments said how he'
look like uh Kingpin and he plays
Murdoch's father in the Daredevil movie
I think oh damn it's actually kingpin's
father in the Netflix series get him
right still cool though cool cool fact
there's someone I need to talk to try
not to leave any dead bodies behind this
time they're going to immediately go
kill some dead bodies was making a
reference to all movies yeah I C it
nothing in here boss it looks like she
dumped this thing and took off if I were
her I'd hit the head and grab a snack
first and then pay off all these parking
citations she got her kid a drink in a
dog and bought a burner phone with cash
keep the change she was in a rush didn't
have time for change Jack rusher can you
zoom in a little I can pop it in but a
lot of the details may be lost wow
realism is playing a Nintendo switch if
we knew a gamertag we could track the IP
address to her device oh my God the
gamer shit's coming back do it yes she
had a switch at Marlo's house every
detail counts I'll take these and a
Clark
Bar call back man love to see it add it
to the national debt un like the
national debt it never has to be
repaid that's the truth suit jacket
Reacher like him this is my vehicle is
there a problem assume her identity just
the uh Commonwealth of Pennsylvania
doesn't permit objects to hang in the
rear viw the rental car company put that
there and uh not so familiar with your
traffic regulations I will remove it in
all due haste along with your head maybe
you can find the grace to give me a pass
on the ticket just give you a warning
forgive me I thought you said no ticket
official warnings still need to be
written up Sir if I could have your
license it'll take me maybe 2 minutes to
run it and then you're on your way
assume her identity slice her her throat
give her plastic
surgery oh that sounds like Terminator 2
music I'll be right back with this
doctor it's like liquid Terminator stuff
and the season has liquid Terminator in
it he's going to show up right behind
them both please run an interstate check
on Colorado driver's license
c17 that's a Sinister shot yeah the dash
cam copy that 5 r41 stand by okay doc
we'll have you out of here
short yeah
uh memory cards man we have an on Dr a
victim of a homicide Rob in Colorado
proceed with caution back up his honest
way what a reversal in real life a white
guy yeah killing the Black hop a guy who
could pass instead of a white cop
killing a black civilian yes true
commentary political commentary people
actually play these things well you
should try one you're like a first-
person shooter I am a first person
shooter KN that was
coming it's a great
line Jane's tag is plain Jane 777 I log
into my own account and play until she
gets back online going to need some
gamer fuel G fuel some G fuel get some G
fuel look at that is that promo code
save 20% got to wait for Jane to get her
game on well until then I'm going to
some sh ey Jack sleeper again it's an
oldie but a ky get in there Dixon get in
there get some shut eye with Jack yeah
sleeps like a vampire Jack dreamer V
preacher I'm so turned on right now
leave the room
sorry we've been attacked by bikers shot
at by Hitman and almost blown up need to
put a m LLY I've got some pent up
tension and I wore my nice bra I know
you've got this rule sleep when you can
but it's not that firm of a
rule I can think of something else firm
though best episode you love to see it
oh my God what was the one in the bed
that I said
oh oh no I said we going use it later
damn it oh where is it it'll come back
it'll come back by the end of the
episode said it in a review section to
use later
D oh smack that ass Reacher little late
for a drop it is everything okay can I
come in of course of course come in sack
Reacher sack in the sack Reacher there
you go we got there what the hell
happened at that Cemetery word is some
hitters were trying to take out fr's
wife so I guess she was wrapped up in
what he was doing huh you know that's
not true I know you saw that Reacher in
his team when they went to Boston and I
know you're working for those guys at
New Age why are you confronting him like
this in the middle of the night you were
a wet behind the ear Punk and you didn't
know which side of your gun the bullets
came out you come in my house and you
talk this [__] to me amazing how much
he's progressed two people knew that
reach and his team went to Boston you
and me and I didn't sell them out to get
jumped so who did Yeah Carl Riner who
did it look the head of security from a
new age that Lon that's right he came to
me when you started poking around the
the France's murder uhoh he backed up a
truckload of cash and all he wanted to
know is what you were finding out where
the investigation was heading he just
wanted updates it's it just updates yes
that's it after 9/11 your NYPD and
you're aiding a betting terrorist he
watch your dad you are suling the
greatest police force in the world
you're spitting on the grave of
everybody who died that day hey hey yeah
I lost more friends that morning than
you'll ever have in your goddamn
life it's really good seamwork yeah D
langon is a businessman he saw a play
and he took it these are crooked cops
these are bading people yeah I've known
guys like him you know guys like him and
your father definitely knew guys like
him this guy's like Serpico man
yeah what are you going to do when you
find out that they lied to you and don't
ever bring up my father again yeah I
knew him well I think about him all the
time and what a good man he was you
don't deserve to say his name that good
man is 6 ft underground I don't want to
go out that way and neither should you
I'm not going to be a good man to honor
his memory all right they paid me
they'll pay you take the Goddamn money
he doesn't take envelopes nope you
didn't know my father and you sure as
hell don't know me yeah buddy business
oh man no now I'm worried for his life
ain't nothing nothing just business oh
Brian depa split Diop
threr look at the kilos coming in this
week I keep getting words she's a
villain yeah me too said it since the
second episode Jo yeah I don't want to
believe it but I am afraid the Colonel's
promotion's going through is going to be
stationed in South Korea at a base right
near the demilitarized zone waiting for
the shoe to drop ense there's no way a
drug operation that happened right under
his nose is going to be publicized in a
huge bust it's not a good look why is
this bad got share the truth cuz the
truth is going to be concealed operation
kaido will be shut down got it this is
[__] don't let our friendship affect
your judgment we don't have a friendship
we have a
familiarity this is what will go into
your report five misdemeanor charges for
drug use only no charges for dealing
conspiracy or misappropriation of
military resources one defendant will do
timing the break four will get probation
all will receive honorable discharges
that's it wow wonder he doesn't want to
be part of this military anymore yeah
same what I signed up for what's going
through your mind right now how the last
big case we all had together how it all
went to [__] at the end and you're
worried how this one's going to end part
of it which part this
part Swan you fixated man I think he's
showcasing a lot more of his internal
pain this season you've done so much for
me me for all of us he trained us so
when the time comes I'll do it I'll kill
Swan of course you will she's got truths
to cover up that's true pull trigger
soon as Jane started gaming she sucks by
the way I had tech services in my office
track her down got us a location an hour
away I followed my
nose happy P She should have used the
informal
too Jack French speaker is this feeling
more like a crime drama now this isn't
your fault Marlo I remember when I left
Thomas it's never easy that window's
getting shattered at some point why are
my sprinklers going off in the middle of
winter I noticed that too jump through
the window I'm going to fire that
grounds keeper yeah I'll be right back
someone go fire on you he knows why it's
going off it's clearly a sign a signal
to leave evacuate meet up with the
messenger or no there's actually
something wrong with the sprinkler would
love if there's nothing to this it's
just like regular domestic
D I thought he was being signaled come
out did Marlo tell you she was running
from an ex-boyfriend she lied to you why
would she do that why don't you call her
out here and ask her yourself cuz right
now I have a colleague in the car
playing online games with Jane to keep
the kid busy if you don't get Marlo out
here I'll go in and get her myself but
there'd be a whole lot of screaming and
caring on him I'd like to avoid
traumatizing her daughter if
possible sure I won't do it OD
Donald switch blade I just love how much
more just he's cutting through all the
[__] this
season it's good intimidation
tactic this is a very specific what is
he doing homemade silencer wow call
Marlo out here I'll shoot you in the leg
scream I shoot you in the head how
silent is that going to make it silent
enough where won't alert other people
can you come out here for a sec can't
believe you fell for that it's a 16th
inch of plastic yeah what it going to do
but regular silences are already still
loud you smiled and gave me an address
where a bunch of thugs were about to
take us out either you're a Chomp or you
gladly threw us into the lion's den when
you found out we took out your guys you
skipped town and used Chad here as a
human shield can I just say shut up
chading Chad shut it our head of
security got spooked when you guys came
around asking question questions he told
me to give you that address oh so now
Langston's in charge not Tony Swan no
he's the one trying to stop all this
hey you would know he'd never be
involved in something like this some of
us do and he'd also never listen to
Hendrick I hired Swan jammed him onto
lon's security team because the new age
of security team was incestuous yeah so
you trusted Swan and I like to think
that he trusted me too that's why he
came to me when he found something
suspicious is going on little wing fly
on everything except how you fit into
all this well I didn't fit into it not
until Swan came to me huh what realized
that chips being uploaded with the
little wing software were being flagged
as defective in numbers outside normal
margin of error yeah management wanted
to fulfill the little wing contract on
time and since the majority of the chips
tested fine we chocked it up to a
processing error and kept cranking out
product sure any idea who in engineering
could have been involved there's scores
of Engineers there's no way to know that
was actually really cool used to
flashback these chips that were being
marked as defective 650 of them that
sounds right yeah buddy I told Swan to
report his findings to Langston because
I didn't know he was involved at the
time but he wanted to do some more
digging he said that he was going to
bring in some of his trusted Army
friends to help oh got it did swan ever
report back about what they dug up I
never heard from him again he just
disappeared he's in hiding not
necessarily you signing off and
shipments as recently as yesterday he's
alive or someone signing for him some
stuff still doesn't make sense though
Langston is vicious he was a detective
for over 20 years and he helped some
very unsavory people avoid jail time
just so he could keep them in his back
pocket I mean like a a biker game took
care of them in
Boston professional Hitmen Brooklyn
cemetery and a lot of General Lo Lives
who would take someone out for a few
bucks buried in Atlantic City you don't
mess with the 110 damn good editing a
rhythm here man yeah after two of you
came around asking questions I was
afraid Langston would see me as a
potential liability there's just great
seamwork in this whole episode we're
looking for someone who recently
hijacked a truck Lotus Sams how
complicated is it to install the
littlewing chips into him he'd need his
engineer to demonstrate but after that
he'd be fine on his own be nice to know
who his engineer is you just have to ask
linkston we will engineer summer results
maybe L has been hiring people and
saying and disguising himself under the
name of the Alias of so that way yeah
people the the army people will one time
will think it's Swan could be maybe L
smarter than we think he is fire will be
landing soon and he's not going to hand
over a penny unless he knows how to
install those chips fire those weapons
like he's rolling out of bed won't be a
problem I will hold his hand and we'll
guide him through the steps I'll kiss
him good night afterwards those two
women who came by asking about copian
they brought a couple of friends to
track me down they threatened me and my
daughter and what did you tell them a
bunch of Lies they're going to figure
that out sooner or later and when they
do I am terrified they're going to come
back for us screed the shadows and if
you did what I said you make a lot of
money and nothing would happen to you
and Janie now I'm a man of my word I can
keep you both safe clearly I I mean
calling from a deli I I think they're
following me so I I have to keep moving
okay okay where could we meet he wants
to kill her he's going to do it himself
don't die don't die yeah you got one job
man and making house calls now only when
shit's about to go down Jack doctor
we're luring Langston in to take him out
get this [__] I got a different job
for
you she works for new age she and her
daughter on Langston's loose end list
Marlo's The Lure need someone to watch
the
kid I need my whole team that leaves you
I saw what you did for Mikey in the
cemetery I know you do the same for
Jane yeah you got a heart man and I also
play Nintendo switch over here he I
cornered Marsh and he cop to being on
Langston's payroll told me to get with
the program and I told him the off and I
took the money of
course I'm going to my cousin's house on
Stan Island for a day or two just in
case I'll bring the girl with me no one
go find you on St Island I love how dark
Darkly lit this episode is but it but
this it still is very striking I don't
need no handicapp and pal trust me I bet
you don't
oh respector I'm going to be back soon
everything's going to be okay I promise
right you have your Nintendo switch you
have your character tra with you do you
remember your
Gamertag you're going to listen to my
voice and you're going to run when I
tell you to run we clear on that whoa
cool shot soon as you're gone we're
going to come up behind him and block
the exit odonald and Dixon will box him
in yeah this episode so far is the most
personality and style to the Direction
real mood here thought the last one did
too but this one
especially
suspenseful stalking angles yeah this is
a really good episode yeah I love this
this is a really really good episode
this has the perfect blend of the tone I
loved the first time around but all the
new elements of the Season you're going
to like Staten Island stop by doas get a
chick and cutless Sandu maybe watch an
Adam Sandler movie or something feel
like something terrible is going to
happen be back with your mom and yeah
please don't they got to have that fight
yeah damn it no no no no but he can see
it he can see get in the back and keep
your head
down Chase let's
go Ram it come on a certain spot the
certain spot of the front of the car I
thought it would bring it
back oh Jesus oh he got one of those
like just stay down automatic pistols D
was an intense ass episode hey they
tracked us down Marsh or Langston I
don't know and I don't give this [__]
it's Russo we got to go wait what's
wrong who the hell is she talking to no
no no no no God damn it oh
no oh
[__]
Jack just running right into the
action
w great drive the bus this is a really
well done episode holy [__] this is
easily the best one yet it's like it's a
constant
build just get more into the shadows as
we go yeah yeah you're in the gritty
underbelly feel feel the environment
feel the weather yeah the squelch
underfoot come
on get in nice that's probably theil
yep as a hero sh just got decar they
found Russo we got to
go oh what are you doing get in go find
Jane I'm not done here I'm staying with
Richard you're not done here Russo's
outmanned out gun and has a kid with him
you all need to go sh get down oh get
down
ow ni
CH o
what a great shot what a great shot holy
[__] damn this is so well composed I'm
heading east keep heading towards Queen
going to intercept oh just Ram right
into
him there you go God damn no one ever
thinks to just shoot the damn tires
thank you steal one of these buses oh oh
great silhouette like a Michael Myers
shot or
something
oh now we're in the perspective of them
trying to hunt him down he's the villain
to
them
oo damn he's in a he's just in a choking
mood this season choker ch squeeze that
truth out Jack Jack truther killer and
him's coming
out like it's not just the not the
soldier but the killer yeah he's letting
some of that rage and grief
out just going to let lure them into
this one bu one at a
time it's like a video
game take it a slow boy all the NPCs
coming in one at a
time
god oh my god dude dude guy's head's
going to come
off third guy in the butt let's
go now we just need Robert Patrick we
got the whole set oh man I just wanted
him to come back in yeah the same scene
[Music]
again nice
dude there's also an excellent use of
the sound is on on the editing of
knowing went to like really utilize the
weather and the thunderstorms they cut
to just silence yeah and even like the
way they cut in the middle of that
scream you just hear it from far away I
love like the Silhouettes the breath
yeah good thing the roads are empty here
in New
York uhoh uhoh no
no you okay okay I'm going move to like
come and get you oh no dude no don't die
do not die I will accept a heroic
wounding and that is all what if Rosco
just shows up I would love that so much
fley told me what was going on I'm here
to
help place is surrounded by barbwire
fence there's only one exit you got to
get past me to reach it
reach a [__] a helicopter please don't
tell me they're going to like lay down
ladder or some [__] W great shot I what
is this episode yeah
Jesus damn Jack can grab the tail and
pull it out of the
sky this is like video game symmetry man
God an air lift
out Jesus Christ man look how bold this
Jack Reacher is I know he's just walking
right out into it jeez
again just the Shadows the gun flare ah
so excellently used this is a
beautifully shot
episode come on man talk about your
dad
flashback God come on get behind the T
come on how many Clips did you bring
with you when I say so you run as fast
as you can I can yes you can I promise I
won't let anything happen to you I want
you to run down that way and whatever
you do don't look back Jack Richard
don't look back he never look back never
look back come on ready I think NY just
got to smash into the bad guys I sure
hope
so needs some sense of relief right now
but give us a cliffhanger when he gets
shot yeah of course damn he just going
head
on yeah he's he's going like a hero no
come on
G damn it this cannot no
no oh get in there Marlo's daughter yeah
go kick the last guy's ass it's not
always Fair
kid yeah and that girl was forever
traumatized yep call 911 copy
[Music]
that I'm going be real upset if he's
dead if he's going to die girl she's
okay she's
safe damn it oh no no what the hell he's
great God damn it oh
man no hold on man hold on man ambulance
is on its
way oh for the love of God please please
be in
time if he just waited like 30 more
[Music]
seconds of course and on the
sirens just had to wait like 30 more
seconds I know if there was one time I
would have welcomed a little bit of
Hollywood movie Magic timing it would
have been
then D ah damn
damn that hurts damn it damn it
Jack should have saved
him
oh I just want to just want to bask in
the vibe of this episode there's no time
because you got to go to a party so yes
I gotta
go got to keep this one efficient today
yes so no shouting out shirts oh but I
love the shirts I know I'm wearing one
right now
uh we're in January right now December
was our most successful month hey ever
thank you guys thank you and a lot of
the sales actually came after Christmas
which surprised me so thank you get
those new year gifts new year new te
people thought they were like some after
Christmas special S no n just exactly
what
they you haven't been around that long
they do some of hey maybe that can be a
new thing is we'll just do a sale after
all the normal sales um but yeah no I I
love those shirts just ordered even more
for me half the sales came for my own
credit
card yeah constantly buying more and
more like the guy who joins the the
network marketing company and just keeps
buying product for himself to climb the
ladder never succeeding actually but
always getting those
numbers uh yeah I mean we if you're
listening to us on Apple and Spotify we
just watched Reacher uh season 2 episode
6 and whilst we have been on a a journey
with this particular season and it it
was a little bit up and down I know for
many people it was already like a solid
like nope this is great right away and
for us it wasn't quite that in the
beginning and then by four I was like oh
this is really starting a dve with me
five I thought was really good and this
was like wow this was I'm loving this
season phenomenal and it's I just paused
this by accident on Director of
Photography Bernard Couture and we don't
often shout out the DPS on these shows
like their named specifically and I'm
glad I accidentally paus it here because
the cinematography on this episode was
phenomenal I thought it was absolutely
excellent it was like the number one
thing I was commenting on uh while we
were watching it because you know like
we have often uh talked about the
distinguishable differences between what
season 1 did and what season 2 did and I
think that this episode uh kind of um
made it all sort of emblematic of what
the season was sort of building to in
terms of its uh aesthetic and voice of
what it wanted to encapsulate because
you're cutting around between Colorado
and New York primarily two very cold
areas one's a busy bustling City and the
other is uh not quite that it's more
naturistic aline as we're seeing it here
yeah yeah yeah and uh there's the main
Spots You're cut in between other than
like flashbacks and here uh I I thought
they really captured like season one's
very uh you know
uh grimy and what's a word that you use
like what's a John word that you use uh
season one is is both like grimy but
it's also got like a lot of air to it
like it's got a lot of it's got that
swampy Southern Gothic flare yeah it's
got a lot of breath in atmosphere and so
does and this one does too but it's much
more cold and for lack of a better word
but they and that's something that I've
been saying that I really wish that they
would um really cap capitalize on and I
felt like they were kind of just doing
that more and more as the season has
been progressing and this one really
brought it to that point where it's like
this is they're in the darkness not just
with the with the characters this is
mainly in the dark so much of this is
shot in the shadows but the way they
allow other elements around them via
NightLight stuff to illuminate uh
certain seam work whether they be gun
flares or just lights descending from
lampost or whatever uh city lights and
car lights there's a lot that they've
been using to uh to just uh enhance the
experience of it but then the breath
that everyone's feeling and you could
feel the coldness whereas the last one
last season you can feel the the heat of
it all yeah you're trading hot and
sticky for damp and cold yeah and I
freaking love it like I just I just love
the commit like to me I'm I'm very much
when people talk about atmosphere um the
thing I'm always kind of uh that's often
like a mood rone and and to me I'm I'm
big on uh feeling the environment yeah
and uh the weather and I and I think
that was such a flavor of last season
and then here you're getting the the the
counter to that uh but it feels very
complimentary with all the characters
you have and then having to but then
yeah when especially there's something
to me about when you see the breath I
think that's something that can often be
overlooked but I like seeing like these
actors really shot the [__] in the cold
you know yeah when you can tell that
it's real fog breath and not like CG fog
breath yeah totally like another show we
were watching I can't imagine what show
you could be talking
about yeah yeah no I I agree with
everything you've said here like this
this was the one that really clicked
together everything that this new season
is doing but with some of the
qualitative flourishes I loved so much
that endeared me so heavily to the first
season and yeah like I love the way that
this episode breathed I love the way it
drew tension and mystery and you know
just the I think the amount of
characters the amount of you know
players in this big you know mination
that's going on with little wi and new
age and all that stuff like it felt
proportioned in a really nice way here
and yeah we got a bunch of really
quality scenes that sung based on acting
and just everything we know up until now
it rewards you for keeping track of the
details but also we got just some really
top-notch performances in these
interrogation moments or like you know
when they're uh luring out and trying to
talk to Marlo in the house and then
Russo goes and talks to that other guy
who's on the take who's you know been
involved with all this mess that they've
you know been dealing with and
everything and just those moments where
you catch yourself and you're like oh
man this we've not cut away from this
like we're just letting the acting and
the and the breath of the scene and the
room kind of carry all this and and
there was that that kind of humorous
moment of like you comment like oh I
love that this Chase is unfolding
without music and the music kicks in
but there are a number of moments
throughout this where I think yeah they
did trust just the environment and the
real tension of just being in the
situation and how loud just silence and
ambient noise can get when you know
you're in some kind of intense
altercation and I think this episode had
a really terrific grip on that that
elevated so many different scenes even
the one brief moment where we check in
with am was appropriately sort of like
harsh and Sinister for what it was and
you felt the cold and you felt the sort
of sad you know poetic Injustice of of
how he just like took out this cop cold
and and just moves on and uh and yeah
it's like all the little details are
great and you know we get a little bit
of catharsis with Dixon and Jack and I'm
still terrified that you're going to be
right especially because we're moving
into the point where Swan is now perhaps
uh going to prove to be on the right
side of things and you know prove that
Jack's Faith you know is good but then
you know maybe they'll come in I don't
know I I can't tell if it's going to be
that his uh you know judgment is sound
all the way through and you know the
suspicions with Dixon will be unfounded
but also I know how Drama Works and that
would be a hell of a you know knife to
stick in our side as viewers she is a
villain she's really committed to the
ACT murdering a lot of langens people
yeah well you know really sometimes
being a double agent is hard you got to
do some uh unsavory choices to sell your
uh your
cover um yeah yeah I completely Echo
that because while you got some scenes
that are a little bit more direct in
terms of its emotionality like with um
oh my God what's cop's name Russo Russo
and his
captain yeah chief of police I I don't
know I got a Serpico yeah well no I mean
Serpico is is Russo because he doesn't
he's no snitch he the envelope that's
that's what a Serpico is yeah have you
not seen C it's been a long time I've
seen the Co the whole thing is he's not
a or maybe it was Caro's way there was a
period of time where you were lending me
all these Pacino movies serpo man so I
should probably watch Serpico again
Serpico serpo reaction baby's great all
no Serpico is the Frank suro was a real
guy who refused to be on the take that's
cool and when everyone was on the take
and uh that is and then in the in the
70s that was like a really big thing
and then he exposed a lot and he was
shunned oh man it was a whole whole
ordeal and uh and he had a big
beard a great big bushy beard that's
that his main main trait is he looked
like a total hippie yeah he had a beard
and
integrity um what's funny about the
movie though is they shot it backwards
because to to make because he he grows
the beard over time in the movie and he
starts off with no hair and he goes and
they had to shoot it they actually had
to shoot it backwards they started with
the most
crazy a hard acting job work the entire
thing backwards got to hope that you got
everything you needed when your beard
was that long so strange anyway um the
but yeah like with that scene between
him and the CH police that was great uh
scene workor where that was more direct
about the the emotions of of uh what
they represent here and like how they
come
from like the dad was the the dad was
like probably like the Serpico would not
not deal with anything dirty and then he
he was surrounded by the amount of
crookedness and stuff but a lot of it
rooted in fearness by going up against
the fear going up against uh the threats
and the Manpower and stuff so that was
more direct but then when you got like
scenes such as the interrogation moment
with Jack Chad and Margo Marlo um them
where that's a little bit more plot
heavy uh and a lot of expositional [__]
what they do so good at is still
capturing the fear that like Marlo's
experiencing and the
intensity and uh the determination
behind what Jack and Company are are
after as well so even though there are
scenes that could still just be
like sometimes the plot Exposition back
and forth scenes can just feel that way
you know just like Bam Bam Bam Rhythm
and then here this episode they really
gave us scenes that were
uh beyond that they were they would they
would do that but they knew to ground it
in some type of immediate emotion that
even if you're not fully keeping up with
all the the [__] they're saying that
you're still latched onto the emotion
the of the scene you know and that's the
most important thing and that was kind
of what was missing for me in some of
the other earlier episodes I'm like yeah
there's a lot of back and forth there's
a lot of scenes you got to build to it I
get it um that's a good observation
though cuz that's what tempers I think
yeah in the first few episodes I was
like okay we got a lot of details and we
got a lot of people and we got a lot of
history that's been told to us but like
to get to the point where we can have
the emotional moments that can transcend
all that and just form the attachment
between viewer and characters yeah you
know that was the stuff that yeah I was
hoping for more of that that has only
grown as the season has gone on and was
the best it's been I think in this
episode yeah and I I loved uh I love
alen Rich's performance this season
around because there's so much
uh you could you can feel the worry in
him that is like rising to the surface
just in his eyes alone I think he's
doing an excellent job and I I think the
guy plays Russo is great it's a fascin
because it could have easily just been
like another Rosco situ not Rosco NE um
Finley Finley it's another Finley
situation and while there's like some
dynamics that you can sort of compare
it's not the same thing and and I really
do like that guy and I'm hoping that
they're just doing some like ending
scene where yeah he's dead and then he
comes back he's in the hospital healing
or some [__] you know I could see it
going both ways with this show but this
is an instance where I would be like oh
yeah please just like let him be alive
deserves a shot to live I think yeah uh
but it would be heartbreaking and and
and very effective cuz I think he gives
an excellent excellent performance and I
like seeing the way how certain seeds
were planted that you kind of just feel
like are passway information that
eventually come back around
little girl being gamer um you know
uh Russo talking with the kid at the at
the funeral yeah these little things
that uh do ultimately factor into the
bigger picture of the Season or to a
later episode uh I really like cuz
sometimes these things happen in an
episode and then they kind of just
happen and you don't really know what
the point of it is and then they come
back into like a later episode yeah it's
like a function of like oh look he's
nice to kids but like
it says something about him in the
previous episode and then it yeah it
sets up this natural you know reason
that he would initially be taken a back
but also like yeah okay I can watch this
kid um and on top of that too uh I just
love how much of a bulldozer Jack is
this time around you know like there was
that one episode in last season where he
was a oneman army but he was like I'm
going to put on my makeup I'm going to
prepare my knives Aquarian I going to do
everything and then here when the when
Marlo's just in the middle of about to
get shot he just runs in start shooting
he like everyone leave I'm G to handle
this yeah I got this I'm a tank yeah uh
me just use my environment uh and yeah
this is a top of just great scenes
throughout even if we didn't get like
the action scenes that was just like the
cherry on top and I just thought it
built to the finale very well where
every scene felt like before it's been
like a political it's been a political
thriller and this brought it to a more
tangible Prime drama yeah you know and
to that makes it more personal when you
that genre in particular I personally
find to be more personal and intimate
and that that's what it I think it I
think that you know what now I think
about it I feel like uh that was the
ingredient Secret Sauce to uh season 1
uh was was that's a crime drama yeah you
know it's not really a political like
there's polit it really felt like crime
drama a first political thrill or second
and then this felt like the inverse
where like political thriller first
crime drama political thriller crime
procedural and the drama yeah kicks in
later and that's the thing you don't
want it to just feel like a procedural
yeah uh I thought this was freaking
awesome it was it was really cool love
this episode The Action was really cool
too yeah it was really really cool
action dudes are going in the bus and
he's just murking him and and yeah like
you said the the Shadows the way they
use the lighting the way they really
make it feel dark and cold and D and
scuzzy and yeah scuzzy was the word I
was looking for yeah it's really nicely
it's nicely handled in a way that's that
is really effective but it's not like in
your face at the same time like it's a
it's yeah it's really nicely Chosen and
even when they pull out some weird lens
or something it's always like well
chosen here yeah yeah there's there's a
lot of shots are that I think could be
very overlooked uh oh yeah like I I love
the shot with the helicopter descending
and Jack running away and yeah there's a
lot of just really well-composed shots
where like damn this took a lot of
thought and only thing that kind of
distracted me is when they're run this
city streets and it's just completely
vacant you're not a movie you're a
show fact that you're doing this with
such clean cinematography like you're
not relying on a bunch of Wild Cuts Like
like you could really keep up the camera
looks really locked on and it's not uh
it's not going all hand hell then and
like cut cut cut cut cut to mask your
your lack of space you had to work with
I'll take car stunts and actual Chase
over vehicle extras yeah it's like if I
got a trade I'll take that yeah there's
so much you can do um but yeah I mean
overall but yeah that was that this was
a really great episode um this this was
truly a a great
episode looking forward to the next two
right two more two more I think all
right we'll knock it out the park guys
thank you so much for being here um if
you're listening us Apple Spotify please
write this video and thank you everyone
who's been on this journey with Reacher
with us and we will catch you all soon
thank you very much
[Music]
bye